[Musique]
nous sommes en 1944 la martinique
souffre des privations de la guerre une
frange de la population tente de donner
un visage à ce qu'il reste de la culture
jean et alexandre restaurer créé avec
marcel misaine le groupe folklorique
martinique pour animer les
représentations qui commence à prendre
de l'ampleur il faut appel en 1946 à
loulou boislaville désormais ambassadeur
de l'île aux fleurs le groupe
folklorique soutenu par l'office du
tourisme représente la martinique
hors des frontières ont voulu autour de
cela avant d'arriver à munich de donner
des spectacles en france métropolitaine
mais les rythmes du monde et les
tranches 2 des mises en scène trouvent
leurs limites lors des représentations
sur les recommandations de riz salvador
le chorégraphe omnium est engagée en
1966 pour parfaire les chorégraphies
c'est la naissance départ des
martiniquais
[Musique]
officiellement je t'ai envoyé
je préparais un compagnie pour les
touristes
ils allaient dans les soirées de bêler
avec mme avec monsieur voit la villa
sainte marie et puis ensuite faire un
recrutement avec cette la base qui
d'iphone outil d'appui faire des ballets
de danse nous dans ce sujet au mois
d'août folklorique mais on ne
connaissait pas on n'avait jamais appris
la chorégraphie et lorsqu'on y est
arrivé il nous a donc eu
montrer un peu comme en cent que l'on
peut faire avec la bim et la masure
câble que nous lui avons appris à danser
la binah masuka après la rupture entre
le promoteur jean pierre bonjour et de
laubois la ville en 1979 la troupe
s'appellera grands ballets de martinique
des générations de danseurs ont donné
vie aux tableaux de ballet qui cette
fois a fait le tour du monde à l'aube de
son 70e anniversaire sous la baguette de
suzon sainte-rose le ballet continue
plus que jamais à faire vivre la récolte
de la canne à sucre ou la vie de la
ronde hier à coups de bill et de mazion
caf
[Musique]